welcome to the reason stream I'm Zack
Weiss Muller joined by my co-host Liz
wolf hey Liz hey Zach today we're
talking about porn specifically the
attempts by some lawmakers to drive
online pornography out of their states
via age verification laws on some level
it's a strategy that seems to be working
as Politico put it recently a simple law
is doing the impossible it's making the
online porn industry Retreat PornHub the
most traffic porn site in America
announced on June 30th that it would
seize operations in Mississippi Virginia
and Utah on account of these types of
laws so our lawmakers write that there's
just too much porn that it's too
accessible it's damaging Our Youth and
ruining relations between the Sexes
joining us today to talk through this is
Aya she has professional experience in
the industry as a former only fan star
and has studied American sexual
preferences and porn consumption habits
in depth by leveraging her large social
media audience to run polls and surveys
that she's then taken considerable
effort to analyze and visualize in
charts and we'll be looking at some of
that data today we'll also be talking
with Aya about her impressions of a
recent debate hosted by the free press
that she attended that asked the
question was the sexual Revolution a
failure a thank you for joining us today
ah thank you for having me on well let's
start by looking at pornhub's response
to the age verification laws uh that
have been passing they posted this as I
mentioned on June 30th and said uh
because elected officials from around
the US have started to introduce laws
aimed at preventing children from
accessing
uh materials harmful to miners
online um they say we think this is
great we've supported this for years
unfortunately the way many elected
officials have chosen to implement these
laws is hazardous and dangerous a number
of States including Virginia and
Mississippi are requiring age
verification of users but they aren't
regulating the enforcement of these laws
and responsible platforms will follow
the law irresponsible platforms won't
uh and they will migrate to other
corners of the internet that don't ask
users to verify age so pornhub's gripe
here is not the law itself but the fact
that there's going to be unequal
enforcement or unequal compliance and
that the big players like them are going
to be the ones that inevitably have to
comply well everyone still finds ways to
get porn porn finds a way um just to
give everyone a sense of of you know
PornHub scope and reach uh you can see
here this is from uh a website called
similar web that that ranks traffic
across the internet and PornHub is the
13th ranked site in the world number
nine in the United States number one in
its category of adult material in the
United States with it total monthly
visits of about 2.4
billion and um what has happened since
these laws have been implemented is
there's been significant legal push back
there's been rulings uh in federal court
uh as Liz Nolan Brown noted for us uh in
early September uh there's a ruling in
Arkansas which has to do with age
verification on social media which we'll
talk about more later and then one
against Texas which is specifically
around porn sites and I want to start
our
conversation talking about the ruling in
the Texas case because it really cuts
right to the heart of what these laws
are all about it it def it defines the
law here quickly as restricting access
to pornographic websites by requiring
digital age verification methods and
warnings about the alleged harms caused
by
pornography the warnings aspect of this
is uh kind of interesting and amusing uh
that these are some examples of the
warnings that must be posted in 14o font
or larger Texas Health and Human
Services warning pornography is
potentially biologically addictive and
proven to harm human brain development
exposure to this content is associated
with low self-esteem and Body Image
pornography increases the demand for
prostitution child exploitation and
child
pornography then here's the kicker the
judge notes that although These Warnings
carry the label Texas Health and Human
Services it appears that the Texas
Health and Human Services commission has
not made these findings or
announcements so we can talk more about
the we're going to talk more about what
we do and don't know about the effects
of porn but one more thing I want to
pull uh in from the from the judges
ruling uh it was a PR preliminary
Junction halting this law on the grounds
that compelled verification chills
protected speech um because first the
restriction is constitutionally
problematic because it deters adults
access to legally explicit material far
beyond the interest of protecting minors
and it has races privacy concerns
because by requiring you to submit
government
identification and this information then
going into a government database you're
essentially giving the state a permanent
database of everyone's porn browsing
history history with no mechanism
requiring them to delete it or who has
access to it and so forth so those are
were among the judge's objections there
were also things like it was overly uh
broad it did things it did this in a way
that was not narrowly tailored uh in a
way to protect Free Speech but Aya what
is
your reaction and response to this law
and the way that the porn industry has
reacted to it I mean like grief or
something and
disappointment um there's a way where a
lot of it's kind of conservative coded
has said a lot about oh um we like
Freedom uh don't Trad on me uh let's
stay out of each other's business um and
there's a way where I kind of hope they
meant it in a more principled manner uh
but instead we are saying that this only
applies for things that they approve of
but as soon as you're uh stepping on to
things that people find like personally
offensive which is why I assume is going
on here uh and suddenly like this
principles no longer apply um I'm really
glad that it doesn't seem to be that it
seems to be being successfully
challenged in some courts
though you know as someone who is a
Texas resident who's provided studied
and consumed a lot of online sexual
material like what are your biggest
concerns about how it's going to affect
the
landscape yeah it depends so this is it
depends on like how much this affects
but like as with most things like for
example with escorting like you
introduce laws that try to prohibit some
things and it just shoves things
underground into places where you can't
uh you can't actually like be safe that
easily like with the back page thing
like they were working with um FBI
people to turn in like people who are
were child molesters child Predators or
traffickers then the whole website went
down and then like boom your whole
access is gone um and so I think of
something very similar is happening here
like if you do want to track uh like bad
porn to some degree but see it's really
funny because like PornHub is one of the
cleanest porn sites on the internet like
everybody ships on PornHub uh for their
content that they have but like as
somebody who tries to post foreign
places uh it's one of the most difficult
and most stringent websites
um so tell us a little bit about that
like what's the what's the landscape I
think most people you know are maybe uh
only fair weather fans of porn sites and
only do a little bit of uh you know
recreational PornHub browsing but give
us a little bit of a sense of like what
are some of the characteristics of
really bad actors in This landscape and
how might this law result in this
unintended consequence of boosting those
Bad actors while punishing
PornHub uh so like PornHub so if you are
a porn actor uh if you're publishing
erotic content on the internet for the
past 10 to 20 years um what happens is
you just it's part of the process that
some people steal your stuff and publish
it online in places you didn't consent
to it's so normal that like we haven't
even processed it and this is an issue
because like nobody has a [__] about us
like about like controlling your content
in like copyright kind of ways um it's
it's s sort of an attitude of like oh
well if you're going to be naked outside
like why you shouldn't expect any sort
of ability to control like the naked
images of you if you're doing this
you're doing it to yourself um and pornh
was like one of the only uh as far as I
know they weren't legally pressured into
it at all they started paying you for
Content that other people posted about
you on their platform um which to my
awareness is the first time that any
porn site started doing this and I was
like holy [__] you're treating us like
humans you don't support stolen content
here um and there's also the problem of
fetishes this is a different topic but
PornHub really doesn't allow a fetish
that are considered maybe a little bit
uh edgy for some people um like what are
some
examples um like if you want uh like
like struggle [__] to some degree
which is a subreddit that was banned in
a a couple years ago um but this is like
more of a phenomenon of the cleansing of
fetishes from the entire internet um
like trans stuff trans fetishes is like
uh anything that like might be
considered sort of morally offensive to
people on the outside uh anything too
kinky um but anyway so like PornHub is
one of the wonderful ones that like
seems to actually pay performers in a
way where they were never forced to and
it seems such a shame that like that's
the thing being pressured underneath and
there's tons of websites that are just
people can post stolen content and you
can do absolutely nothing about it are
you disappointed in any sense that
PornHub the stance that they're taking
here is we support the law just we don't
like that it's only weird going to be
the only ones complying with it um
instead of taking a
more expansive or strident opposition to
the idea that this is a good way to
regulate or prevent children from
accessing pornography is is that what
they I thought they maybe I
misunderstood I thought they were like
we pull it up in a second here we
disapprove of uh the way that this is I
think I thought they said they approve
of like trying to prevent minors from
accessing yeah
uh let's see we've started to introduce
laws aimed at preventing children from
accessing material harmful to minors
online this is okay yeah you're right
they saying this they've supported that
notion um if not necessarily the the law
itself so yeah that's seems to like yeah
a very publicly safe thing to say and a
lot of people like in good faith I think
support this I personally think that we
are like way overly stringent about kids
sexuality but I understand that point
might disagree and there's a question I
just saw that kind of goes to this point
Jason etaria says why not just have porn
sites on a separate domain then parents
can actually control access this was an
issue that was brought up in the lawsuit
is the idea that you could have
something like better content filtering
so that's what you know me as a parent
would want access to is just tools that
really enable me to have a more control
over what my kid can get to on the
internet and if there was a law that had
more to do with you know saying a
browser has to have a certain level of
content filtering or something like that
like still don't think that's ultimately
G to that there's always going to be
workarounds but at least that would be
more theoretically defensible to most
well I just want to raise the VPN
objection here I mean yeah most
consumers of porn I would imagine are
basically like probably teenage boys up
to you know actual male adults um pretty
much everybody is technologically able
to use a VPN and so I'm curious about
like does this just slightly raise the
costs um of actually accessing porn but
like how airtight is this really what do
you think
Aya yeah I don't people will find porn
is like one of the most powerful things
and if you're a teenage do you remember
being a teenage boy I remember it well
yeah you how how much do you think these
content filters would have stopped you I
yeah I you know this guy here Sandman
speaks to this point he says learn from
the War on Drugs you cannot ban anything
people will always find ways to get what
they want and there will be someone to
supply it and I agree with you a that
especially in a case where the the Drive
is so strong people will find a way and
the way to do it is fairly easy and it
is VPN like everyone
knows most people
uh it's not that hard to download a VPN
um most people uh are technically able
to do it and certainly a you know
15-year-old boy who's a motivated enough
to uh get to it is going to figure out
that workaround um and and so I think in
some sense yeah we're going to just uh
like if if this trend continues uh that
you're going to just see it's going to
be a boon for the VPN industry uh and
I'm I'm fine with that but uh it's still
worth it you know in the interum to you
know we want to be if if we want a
maximally free world then we want to be
working we want to have the the exit
hatches like the VPN the workarounds but
also you know fighting um and supporting
fights on on the legal front as well I
want to yeah go ahead I I was gonna say
I feel like a lot of this is coming from
a misguided place like to some degree I
think we should question the idea that
we should be protecting kids from
exposure to sexuality at all like like
there's this weird phenomenon where
we're treating teenagers like they don't
have a sex drive and like aren't
shouldn't be allowed any access to any
sexual content at all
um and I'm like that feels so strange to
me and and like dehumanizing in a way I
feel like ideally we should be giving
them sort of like sexual content that
they desperately want but with a lot
more education about it they're gon to
be doing it anyway what does that look
like like in your ideal view of the
world I assume that doesn't mean
trusting State Departments of Education
to appropriately administer sex ad right
I mean school is deeply [__] up as an
institution but if we had to use it I
would say like maybe have like like in
your class about sexuality I'll have a
section on pornography be like hey here
are the incentives when people are
shooting porn the incentives are
different from the kinds of incentives
you have when you are having sex uh here
are examples of scenes in porn that you
should not be extrapolating to real life
um and I think like it's really
uncomfortable for us as adults to think
about doing this like with people who
are underage um but underage people are
people also they're legitimate people
with full sexualities and it's just like
feels insulting and dehumanizing to
treat them as anything else and that
proposed would have the positive
consequence of also teaching people
about incentives which we as
Libertarians can very much get behind
because that seems to be ignored in most
public schools these days uh but I am
curious I mean do you see um a place for
the sort of parental rights argument
that Zach is making like I think about
this you know I have a very young son
right now but navigating this in the
future I think like well I I see my role
in his life as like this this Steward of
you know attempting to sort of sus out
as best I can which you know admittedly
probably won't be perfect a sense of
what type of material is age appropriate
and the ways to attempt to provide
behind the scenes context so that he can
develop healthier ways of thinking about
you know sexuality or or violence in the
world or processing grief like any sort
of hard thing I see the role of the
parent as sort of you're this
intermediary between the kid and the
outside world and you you take on
ideally less of that intermediary role
to some degree as they get older and as
you know they are more and more
independent but how do you look at that
tension between parental rights and also
as you said treating a minor like
they're a human too I mean like is the
question are there some parents that
don't treat their kids like humans well
I think I think the question of like if
if we place this firmly in the parental
rights Camp of like every parent ought
to be able to decide for themselves for
their minor child under the age of 18 um
you know what type of intern content
they feel comfortable with them
accessing this creates a problem where
some parents will probably draw that
line in a really you know what you would
considered to be a bad spot so how do
you look at this in terms of like making
sexual material more pervasive for
underage children even if that means
sort of flouting the wishes of their
parents well I mean you can do both I
don't like you can do a thing where you
allow parents to behave as they want
with their kids I guess public school is
a deeply [__] institution and I guess
that's hard because parents that of have
to vote on what their kids are exposed
to I'm like a pro homeschooler
whatever way I'm GNA in Good Company
here yeah yeah so in my fantasy world
it's like we like people like us would
go out and do messaging like hey guys
treat your kids like
people and but we wouldn't I don't agree
with the use of force like I think
adults should be allowed to I see this
with a lot of like on discomfort but um
like I think parents should be allowed
to uh trying to say the words like treat
your child as subhuman but like
it's say that I don't I really hate it
the only problem is I'm saying it's
because the alternative is so much worse
like it's like either the parents do or
the government does it
and yeah it's it's a it's a thorny issue
uh that once you get into like you know
the that that line between you know
tolerating different parenting Styles
and you know when is some sort of
intervention from the state need to
happen um typically we draw that at we
at something we call abuse but even that
gets complicated when you start to talk
about psychological abuse um you know wi
with regards to the the um the age
verification law and the um the the way
that the the re the the reason that
these are picking up steam and the
reasons that the rationale that is given
for these types of law these laws tends
to be not necessarily that teenagers
should never see a naked woman or
something like that but that there's
something specifically wrong with online
porn the sheer quantity and volume of it
the lawmaker be the the lawmaker behind
Louisiana's age verification ban which
is the one that really got the ball
rolling on this uh to make online porn
lless accessible uh apparently was
motivated by an interview that she heard
with Billy eish the popular singer that
she gave to Howard Stern in 2021 about
her personal experiences with online
pornography I'd like to roll that clip
and get aa's reaction to what she's
saying about the effects that she thinks
porn had on
her as a woman I think porn is a Grace
and I used to watch a lot of porn to be
honest I started watching porn when I
was like 11 I thought that's how you
learned how to have sex I was watching
um abusive porn to be honest you know
when I was like 14 and I you know
thought I was one of the guys and would
talk about it and think it was really
cool for for for not having a problem
with it and not seeing why it was bad
and I think it really destroyed my brain
and um I feel
incredibly devastated that I was exposed
to so much porn I think that I had like
sleep paralysis and these like almost
like night terror SL just nightmares
because of it I think that's how they
started because I would just watch
abusive BDSM I couldn't watch anything
else like unless it was violent I like
didn't think it was attractive and I had
was a virgin I I had never done anything
and and so I I let it it led to problems
where you know the first the first few
times I you know had sex I was not
saying no to things that
were not good and it's because I thought
that that's what I was supposed to be
attracted to and I just I am I'm so
angry that porn is
so loved and it's how so many people
think that they're supposed to learn
it's how so many men think that they're
supposed to be and because in and
there's no
consent like getting thrown around
during sex if you're not interested in
being slapped and being choked people
are like you're vanilla you're soft
you're that's not you're boring in bed
and I'm not talking about me I'm talking
about women women are like oh I have to
like being hurt to be thought of as good
and
bad what do you think about the
experiences she's recounting there that
porn just it warps your expectations to
of what sexuality could and should
be I'm like slightly confused by her
accounting like why where did she get
the idea that being hurt like the
abusive porn was the cool porn like was
she around a bunch of other like Preen
being like hey did you watch this
violent BDSM like I I've I I I just I'm
Legit imately confused like maybe it's
possible that there's whole cultures out
there like when I first when she first
started talking about I'm like oh she's
just into it and then like hasn't come
to terms with the fact that she's kinky
but then she said she didn't actually
find it attractive so I'm like why are
you it it takes quite a lot of like
cultural um force in some way to like
make people regularly watch porn that
they're not aroused by like have you
ever tried watching porn you're not
aroused by like ever right right how
much done that right like so this is why
I'm just confused again I'm not saying
that like that she's like incorrect or
something I'm just I noticed that
something's not adding up here um yeah I
mean I know you have written about the
about violent porn and you know she the
way the way she's laying it out there is
the is it's like it makes men want to
engage in really rough violent sex and
then women feel like they have to like
that too
your your writing on this uh and your
your research seems to show that it's
actually women who have a preference for
more violent pornography could you talk
a little bit about that yeah absolutely
I mean like like to to pump our
intuition here you look at Women's
romance novels um there's a lot of like
pretty aggressive men who are not that
interested in consent uh and this is
like written by women for women um 50
Shades of Gray most popular selling
women's novel and I don't think that
it's because women are desperately
trying to please men so that they go and
make this novel so popular that like
most men don't give a [__] about um and
basically every yeah like that the the
thing that you pulled up um I I did a
survey where I asked people partially my
audience and partially people I paid who
are random who have no association with
me um and I asked like men what to
predict what they thought that women
would like in bed like hey let's say you
try oh wait actually oh this might be a
different I forget I WR a couple
different blog posts so I get them mixed
up but I've got a couple of your graphs
here that maybe we could talk about that
will be a way to talk about it this is
the one where you asked how often do you
read or watch erotic content for the
purposes of arousal and it shows that
overall
unsurprisingly CIS men watch and read
more arotic content than women but then
you ask how much of the porn you watch
is violent um um CIS men there's uh you
know over 30% said none for women that
number is lower 25% so it's the you know
the absolute number of men watching porn
unsurprisingly is higher but of the
women who do watch porn they are more
likely than men to watch violent porn
and like the theory where it's like oh a
pressure from men is causing women to
want like maybe you could be like oh
women are reporting that like violent
porn because they're trying to please
men but like let's say we're in a world
where we have like say 40% of men really
like violent porn and like in in truth
only 10% of women do and then we have a
bunch of cultural pressure from the men
like oh more women should like violent
porn um I wouldn't expect the number of
women that like violent porn to get shot
up that that degree like I maybe I would
see some inflation like oh now it's like
15% or 20% of women are reporting it but
like the fact that now more women than
men are reporting interest in violent
porn like that's just doesn't seem to be
really consistent with this
Theory yeah I I want to get a little bit
a few more of your your findings on
human sexuality because that that you
know you you have these huge samples
like how do you remember off top of your
head about how big that uh your your
survey was where you're drawing this
data from it's still coming in uh now
it's 622,000 cleaned okay but more than
that uncleaned depending on how you
clean it yeah yeah so I mean that that's
a huge sample and I was looking through
some of it some of your results in
preparing for this one was this uh what
women say they like versus what men
predict women will like because it's you
know the the idea that Billy eish is
putting forth in that clip is that porn
sort of warps men's Brains to make them
think women want different things than
they actually want uh but if you look
here I mean it's like the the the the
most popular answer on both sides you
know like call her beautiful and sexy
kissing conolingus missionary with legs
up like it's matching almost it's not a
perfect match but it's it's pretty close
um I mean was that were those kind of
results at all surprising to you or what
what do you make from that data I mean
the fact that they're close isn't like
overall close is not that surprising I
try to have like a broad spectrum from
like extremely vanilla and like
everybody likes it to like extremely bad
like very few people like it so yeah
like the lowest one here is like uh like
tell her she's ug call her ugly or like
shove her head in a
toilet both sexes agree that that's not
uh that's not sex rims you that's
another one that is just you know not
quite catching on just
yet um but but so yeah there's there
doesn't seem seem to be there don't seem
to be a lot of men answering that you
know you should that they think shoving
a woman's head in a toilet or like
pissing on her face is the I asked that
one because once the guy shoved my head
into a toilet and I was like
huh wow it was
interesting I don't think it's thing but
like I'm glad to have experienced
it I mean touching the water or like how
far in did your head no very close to
the water I thought that I thought he
was GNA show
would that have changed your
appreciation of it of the experience I
don't think so I think I mean I I would
prefer not having my head shift in any
more toilets yeah but I like it's just I
don't know it's like interesting to go
through that experience because like
yeah when do you ever get the
opportunity to have your head shift in a
toilet very infrequently in my daily
life unfortunately apparently sorry I'm
a journalist so I have to ask the
important followup questions thanks for
thanks for digging into that one uh you
know it's like a a problem that we run
into often in 2023 America is like
anytime there's a potential downside or
harm to some products whether that's
porn or drugs there's like almost an
assumption that therefore State
prohibition or at least regulation is
the remedy and I think all of us in this
conversation reject that notion none of
us are for Banning porn even if some of
us think kids should have you know
unmitigated access to it or that porn
might be bad for some people I think
though that if we want to move towards a
Freer Society where we leave more
responsibility with individuals to
moderate themselves instead of relying
on the state to Nanny us it's going to
require honest discussion about
downsides or pitfalls we don't have to
like something or celebrate everything
to tolerate it and I just want to give
that preface before we talk about a
little bit more about some of the major
criticisms of the online porn industry
um many of which were raised in this
article for skeptic magazine called how
porn is messing with your manhood which
was authored by three writers who've
written full books on what they see as
the The Scourge or the downsize of
online porn and I just want to bring up
a couple of these with you a because
there are criticisms you hear common and
I want to know if you think there's much
to them um and if so if there's anything
that can be done realistically to
mitigate this other than trying to
implement a porn ban that certainly
won't work um one of this uh one of
these ideas is what the author calls
sexual anorexia and he bases a lot of
this argument off an Italian uh survey
that found that um
you know by sexual anorexia he means
difficulty having sex with a real
partner so the researcher Professor
Carlo Foresta explained that the problem
worsens when young men's sexuality
develops independently from real life
sexual relationships he said viewers who
watched a lot of porn especially if they
started early 14 years old um became
less responsive first to the porn itself
and then their libido dropped and
finally it becomes difficult to get an
erection and there is some you know
wider empirical data showing the rise of
uh erectile dysfunction among younger
men worldwide and in in America as well
we can't directly link that to porn but
it's a
phenomenon um but what do you is that
something you've observed or have any uh
anything to say about the the idea
that men can become reliant on porn for
sexual release and then don't know what
to do in a real life situation with a
woman yeah there's some some like a
professor friends I have that say that
like sex porn addiction isn't a real
thing um and I am not sure that I find
that convincing you just need to find
like one person who like a good
introspection who reports like hey I
feel like this is damaging my life and
you can get addicted to so many things
it just feels weird to be like you can't
just to put like a pin in one end of it
but on the other end it's like difficult
for me to under to like trust a lot of
the research on this because it's so
motivated in both directions people are
really personally offended by
pornography and there's also um the
there's a lot of uh incentive for
self-insight to go arai here like um
like if you are say for example having
erectile dysfunction problems for other
reasons like that might be health
related um it might be very easy for you
to try to find a causal thing that that
you're aware of like oh maybe it's the
porn that's doing it we see this with
fetishes all the time a lot of my data
doesn't support that childhood
experiences correlate with fetishes and
yet we constantly have narratives like
oh I think I'm into this thing because
you know I was spanked as a child or I
wasn't spanked as a child or something
um so I just am like very up close and
personal all the time to the way that we
can like make stories connect with our
lives in ways that turn out to be
completely fake um and I'm not saying
that they are always fake I'm just
saying that like when I'm reading people
making like causal claims about this
it's just something you have to be super
super careful about we have to really I
have to pick through the study um and
like try looking at different questions
to try and coordinate like triangulate
what the answer might be um I think a
lot of the discussion around porn
addiction um is misguided for this
reason I I would be surprised if it were
all true but again I would be surprised
if none of it were true I so my guess is
that por addiction is like a legitimate
problem where it is [__] some people
up I guess it's a smaller number of
people than a lot of this discourse
currently is claiming yeah on on the
issue of fetishes that was another topic
that they raised in this article that
because on these porn sites you can
effortlessly click from scene to scene
and genre and genre to genre to your
arousal it's like you've put yourself in
a Skinner box like the change means that
you can just condition they say
condition your arousal patterns to an
ongoing escalating and everchanging
Novelty so thus users are conditioning
their sexual arousal template to
everything associated with their porn
use their brains then expect these
things during sexual arousal yet none of
these attributes of online porn match
sex with the real person who can compete
with the buffet provided by porn so the
argument boils down to it's giving you
porn brain um you get sucked down these
very specific fetish rabbit holes um is
there anything to that uh have you
observed that either in your survey data
or you know dealing with real life
clients this is the thing I'm much more
sus about like the other things like
important R your life maybe but this I'm
like I just this feels so much more
skeptical like uh in my theory currently
which take up the great I may come back
and be like actually I've updated this
based on more data but currently my
theory is that there's like kind of two
categories of uh like ways that you can
have a fetish and one is that it has
early onset and it is quite strong so
like you typically people in this
category remember their fetishes
happening like some of their earliest
memories just like an intense
fascination with this thing and now this
thing as an adult is quite Central to
their sexuality and then secondarily you
have a l late onset and this is due to
some kind of conditioning and it's
usually much milder so this is kind of
like guy who girlfriend puts her hair up
in a ponytail every time she gives him a
[__] and now he's out and like sees a
girl put her hair in a ponytail at a
grocery store and he like gets a chub
like that's what I would consider to be
like conditioned sexuality um and but
usually they're not uh like fetishes in
the classic sense that we think of that
term like they're not super strong um
but you I think the way most fetishistic
SE works is very similar to sexual
orientation some people uh like latch on
to feet some people latch on to like
being gay honestly I think latching on
being straight is like the default one I
don't think that these are meaningfully
different um but uh and we know how well
gay conversion camps work we know what
happens when we try extremely hard to
recondition people's sexuality um in the
terms of orientation uh it's basically
incredibly ineffective and so like this
is why I have quite a bit of Doubt when
it comes to reconditioning like deep
sexual
in other regards like if you can't make
somebody attracted from penises to
vaginas like you're not going to be able
to make somebody become that level of
attracted to like feat or bondage or
something you can do like the
conditioning thing like your girlfriend
puts her hair up in a ponytail but
there's no way you can change a fetish
on the level of like this happened early
and it is deeply Central to my sexuality
no way let me ask just since yeah I
think that for all of us this comes down
to a sense of personal responsibility
we' rather see people be able to cope
with this uh kind of endless Buffet of
porn rather than you know have the
government close the buffet
down do you have any thoughts or advice
or anything you've gained uh from
experience over time over you know what
do you think like a healthy relationship
with online pornography looks like like
what's the best case scenario for
someone using it in a healthy and
productive way well first I think we
just need a lot more research like like
good neutral research not people like
really invested in having one outcome or
the other to know what the actual
effects are on it psychologically how
much of it is like cultural information
about like or cultural conditioning
about what you're supposed to feel
versus like what you actually feel that
sort of thing um and once we have like a
good array of information then I think
we can move forward a lot more education
but a lot of it's just like education in
general like these kids are finding porn
and because adults are too afraid to
talk about porn with their kids kids you
get kids experiencing porn in isolation
of like knowledge of what actual sex is
supposed to be like and so I think like
developing like getting over our
squeamishness and developing like a more
intensive like sex education system not
just about half sex works but about like
what are the Dynamics of sex like what
are fishes what the what are The Kinks
and a lot of um like right-wingers like
make fun of wokes for this purpose
they're like oh you have a kids book
with like a lot of genitalia in it and
you know showing criticism like that is
what we need we need like direct
exposure to this like to tell you what
you're going to see and how to orient to
it yeah I mean it's not just making fun
of it's uh calling people groomers for
suggesting that um and I mean again I
think the where it gets into really
dicey territory is when the public
school system is introducing these
Concepts in ways that are tend to be
really simplified and crude um but I
don't disagree with your broader point
that you know from a on a more local
let's say familial and parental level
that uh communicating openly about this
stuff that seems like and and and trying
to you know just give your kids an
understanding of like what the what the
reality is out there and what the um the
state of the psychological research is
to the degree that you can convey that
and also the uncertainty um I think that
it has to be part of the conversation I
mean one thing I'll push back a little
bit because I want to make sure that
we're representing the right wiers
arguments correctly aside from yes they
do a lot of calling people groomers and
yes there's a lot of uh you know
attempts to remove books from school
libraries uh and I think we are all
Libertarians and want to see um less of
that [__] as much as possible but I
do think their argument would be and I
don't I'm curious to hear you pick this
apart or react to it AA is like a book
like Maya kab's gender queer which uh
has a strapon in it uh and I think
there's like a [__] with a strap on
which is confusing because it's like why
would you do give a [__] to a strap
on anyways I digress um but like you
know I think most right-wingers would
say hey I don't want my eight-year-old
to access that maybe you know when
they're 15 16 and it's a time when
they're sort of more sexually developed
uh to be able to contextualize like what
a strapon is or the different fluids
mentioned in that book right like like
maybe then but I think to that to some
degree and I I don't think that they
articulate this argument very well most
of the time it's it's an age
appropriateness question how do you look
at this AA is it wrong for parents to be
thinking in those terms at all because
it attempts to put sort of structures
and boundaries on the child's sort of
like natural development or is there
some legitimacy to parents sense of like
okay well you know maybe like a little
bit later is appropriate for having
access to that type of material versus
really early I mean to be clear I think
parents should be allowed to do the
thing I'm not arguing that like oh
should change it but if I were
personally giving advice which is a
little silly here but I my homeschooling
Co-op like curriculum sex ad consultant
AA is what I'm saying though of course
I'll I'll compensate you for your I I
guess it's like we just don't trust kids
enough is my my suspicion like kids are
not interested in sex like before they
like go through puberty maybe they're
like curious about in the same way
they're curious about everything but I'm
like if you show a kid a strap on before
puberty how is this going to hurt them
like how do you need to contextualize
you should be like oh adults do a thing
where they put their genitals together
and you'll get it when you're older like
I just don't understand how just like
exposure to knowledge about the world
can be damaging for a child unless
you're trying to interact with them
inappropriately I think maybe this is
why we have so much squeamishness is
because like historically the only
context in which a child is learning
about sex is if they're being like
inappropriately interacted with um and
so we really associate these two things
and we're like oh God but like what does
appropriate mean you know like I mean I
think that's a good philosophical
question I guess what I'm curious about
is like is there any Credence to the
parents like I'm trying to just think
about what the rightwing argument is to
the best of my ability and I would
imagine one of the pushbacks that they
would offer there is that like you know
communicating any detail or or providing
even like the visual imagery of like a
strap on or like I don't know like BDSM
like leather apparel and like you know
whips uh in a sexual context to a child
sort of like begins to get them sort of
prematurely interested in sexual
activity in a way where like maybe they
would have developed that interest in
you know at age 13 or 14 but the fact
that they were exposed to it at age n or
whatever means that now they're sort of
you know possibly going to experience
more of this like sexual blossoming in a
way that leads to earlier sexual
activity in a way that like maybe their
maturity just like isn't quite there for
them to be able to figure out how to do
that
well I mean I don't think maturity for
13 year olds is there to figure out how
to do it well either like it's like I
think maturity to be able to do this
well I think I mean if your question is
like hey we just don't want to like have
to be dealing with the fact that our now
our nine-year-old is like trying to do
sexual exploration like I think this is
like kind of a fine argument but uh but
like it
takes I I my bar for uh like protecting
kids I think is quite high and again I'm
not like I'm not saying you should just
put all this stuff in front of them but
if a kid is naturally curious and like
well how does sex work like what do
people do like well most people have do
this class thing like I'm just I just
feel like trying to hide information
that they naturally want to know um
feels like a little much I wonder
whether actually this makes me think of
the fact that like I wonder whether
people are getting so riled up about the
school library stocking in particular
because it's almost to some degree the
opposite of what you're describing where
like the platonic ideal of this is that
the parent offers um useful context and
information and has a discussion with a
child and it doesn't personally act
squeamish but is ble to sort of hear
where their child's at and tailor their
response and provide some information in
a way that is appropriate and in a way
that's like ideally done in like a
loving environment where the parent um
you know is prioritizing their kids
safety and health above absolutely
everything and so the fact is when you
stock you know books in a school library
you're kind of making it so that the kid
just kind of has access to that and
without any of that contextualized the
parents might not even really know what
they're accessing if they're only doing
that at school but then at the same time
so like I can sort of understand that
objection but then at the same time you
know vpn's exist and the whole white
internet exists so if a child wants to
access that type of material like
there's no really there's no such thing
as like a book Band anymore because you
can gain access to practically any book
if you have enough text savy um but I do
want to move us to a broader discussion
about sexual morice and the question
that was posed really recently at the
free presses debate uh in Los Angeles I
believe
two weeks ago uh and it was very
provocatively titled has the sexual
Revolution failed um I was super Bumm to
miss it uh I was invited but we were
actually in uh reason's offices in DC it
seemed like a really interesting event
it was anakan of redcare and Louise
Perry um who's a wonderful author though
you may disagree Aya um arguing on the
side of yes it has the sexual revolution
has failed and then it was Sarah hater
who's a wonderful podcaster and the
music musician Grimes um on the side of
you know the sexual Revolution
absolutely has not failed uh it has been
successful um so I wanted to roll the
clip from Louise Perry first and get
your reactions because I hear that you
were in the audience Aya and you had a
really interesting Twitter thread after
this and I mean I'm just curious about
what the vibe was what types of
discussions stemmed from this and how
you reacted specifically to Louise Perry
and anak kian's arguments so if we could
roll the Louise per clip that would be
great Reformation was the rejection of
Catholicism the second Reformation which
we are still experiencing I would say is
the rejection of Christianity and
actually of religion per se so all of
that permits abortion permits the pill
all of this and what they do in
combination is they act as a sort of
acid on the very fragile system of
sexual Norms that had developed in order
to regulate
heterosexuality right and what I think
we're seeing
is what I'm going to describe as the
homosexual of
heterosexuality so basically a
trend basically a trend towards seeing
greater male preferences in the sexual
culture you know in the same way that
obviously you would expect to seeing gay
male sexual culture because it's
entirely composed of men right you're
seeing that in the straight dating world
as well so more casual sex more kind of
anonymous sex more porn more tolerance
for fetishes all of this stuff you know
Sex in the City is actually a TV show
made by and about gay
men
like they admit this you know Samantha
the horny one she was based on a real
person a man the writers have said as
much right but the problem is that Sex
In The City Is So emblematic of this
idea that having sex like a man and Def
that's what they call it in the first
episode having sex like a man is
aspirational and I heard from so many
women cuz they email me all the time who
say that they lent into this they tried
so hard to prioritize sexual
freedom and it made them
miserable do you Aya
fundamentally support or reject that
argument that the the shift uh toward
women [__] like men has made them
miserable uh some women sure also some
women [__] like women has made some
women miserable the thing is like
there's a like a distribution of sort of
how sociosexual women are from we have
like Little Women Pride and Prejudice uh
narratives and then we have sex in the
city narratives that are representing
like sort of different subsets of
women's sexuality both of these are
legit um there are a lot of women who
are very legitimately like Sex in the
City kind of women who really like
casual sex and do it well and there's a
lot of women uh for whom that lifestyle
would be atrocious and like ruin them
same for the other side like I think
this is one of my issues is that there's
a diversity um of women and I feel like
often Louise Perry and people like her
sort of are trying to smash women into
the pride and prees side um where it's
like well true women actual women women
who are like women they want you know
the one romantic partner for the
entirety of their lives but I did in
response to this question I did a survey
both again of my audience and paid
responses where I asked women um
basically what's your like if your
idealized self would have how many
sexual partners and then how much how
many partners do you think society would
want for you um so basically figure out
like do do women feel more pressured by
Society to have more Partners or fewer
Partners than they want um and do you
want to guess the answer to this I
honestly kind of don't know what it
would
be um for it was the women wanted to
have sex with more Partners yeah
interesting both both my audience and
the Rand the randomized sample that I
get which I get from posit Le tends to
be much more conservative a little bit
older um more like monogamous less
exciting they still wanted more sexual
partners it was only a little bit they
wanted a little bit more sexual partners
but they definitely reported that
Society they would get more shamed I
asked a whole bunch of questions about
like I I'm in the middle of writing this
up I should have it published soon but I
asked questions about like do you how
much like social punishment would you
get if a woman like had sex with a lot
of men versus didn't have sex with that
many men um like how what that we're
talking about like how did you um lump
or how did you create the levels of it I
did um it depends on the question I need
to look at the exact ones but it was
like one of them was like how many women
can a woman how many men can a woman
have sex with before she's going to
start finding a little bit of difficulty
finding men willing to date her okay and
then another question for a lot and so
people would input a number for they
thought was like around the range um
stuff like that and overwhelmingly uh
deviant in either direction was
published by Society but deviant in the
direction of being more promiscuous was
publ punished more um so I don't know
it's like it's like like Lis like isn't
wrong uh for a certain subset of
women yeah right but um isn't yeah just
to try to put a little bit more meat on
the bones of her argument there isn't
she saying in some sense that you know
even if women especially when they're
younger
because they've watched a lot of Sex in
the City or just because the culture has
become more permissive pursue the pursue
a more promiscuous lifestyle but then in
the end it's it's bad for everybody as
they get older because they haven't
formed the relationship that is going to
lead to you know a happy family kids all
the and then they're ends up being a
sense of regret later on in life and
that that the trend has gone too far in
that direction and needs to be pulled
back in this direction and you know
there was talk of marriage rates birth
rates and all that sort of stuff to that
she was using to try to bolster her
argument do you think there's anything
to that I guess it's like birth rates
don't have a ton to do with this I think
my think is birth rates have more to do
with overall feminism as opposed to like
the sexual Liberation part just like
okay women want you know richer men and
you know men are not getting college
degrees like that sort of thing um but
wait I forgot the first part of the
question oh just that there's regret
later in life that you know this has
been sold to you as a as a young woman
but then later on things change I know
it's like it's interesting that like I
like yes I think this happens but it's
interesting how only one side of social
pressure is talked about here like oh
we're talking about sex in the city and
you know women are being conditioned but
like are we forgetting like every Disney
movie and like every romance novel and
Twilight and like where it's like
monogamous relationship surprise and
like 50 Shades of Gray where she's a
like a virgin or something I like has
one sexual partner like the vast
majority of romantic media for women is
like really selling the uh like the prud
narrative if I can be so bold I mean
it's fine to to be it's like it's
totally fine if you want that but it's
just like we pick out like oh like the
the couple things about promiscuity and
we're like this is conditioning women
I'm like if women are being conditioned
we should look at the entirety of media
and I think that the answer is not going
to be the thing you're arguing for which
and that like bothers me a little bit
although isn't that that that's changed
over time though wouldn't you concede
that you know if you look at something
like Disney movies what the princess was
doing in Cinderella is not the same as
whatever's happen you know Moana and
where there's a more active like you
know pursue your dreams type
of having sex with you know 20 men okay
yeah there's no promiscuity that Disney
is not about sex but it's it is about it
is portraying gender roles in a certain
evolving way yeah I agree and I think
there is a discussion I'm like to be
clear I'm glad that we have feminism but
I'm not gonna say it's not without side
effects a lot of which are being born by
men I think that's true I think that's a
really good and natural transition to um
our anakan clip who uh sort of basically
is like new Camille Pia which I think is
very interesting I do also want to
mention uh just if any of our viewers
are uh enjoying uh watching these clips
or enjoying hate watching these clips
the Free Press is publishing the full
debate uh to their website today I
believe it's for paying subscribers only
right now but you should absolutely go
over there and watch the whole thing uh
kudos to them for hosting this it seemed
really really interesting and I
absolutely cannot wait until they do the
next one but let's on that topic though
of you know whether the question of like
how feminism plays into the sexual
Revolution and the degree to which are
we living in a patriarchy are we living
in a matriarchy perhaps you know are
women miserable if so like why are they
so miserable Anan had some really
interesting insights on that can we roll
that that all of us here on stage are
the winners of the sexual Revolution and
the sexual Revolution is the winner of
the culture War we finally found a way
to have it all and yet we're still not
happy realistically men really only had
a few Decades of enjoying the fruits of
the pill before Title 9 and me too made
male sex seuality presumptively
illegal and yet here we are still having
the same debate from the same
assumptions women are objected
objectified and oppressed though it's no
longer clear by whom the patriarchy is
alive and well though apparently there's
also a crisis of masculinity no offense
but the idea that we live in a society
where men are in charge is funnier than
anything Tim Dylan has ever said both
men and women are invested in
maintaining the fiction that women are
the fair sex not operating out of of
ordinary incentives just like everybody
else um if you disagree you're either
Autistic or an incel or both which means
you're right
wing and you're not entitled to an
opinion um the problem we now face is
that this unofficial style has been
officially baked into the system the
most problematic Legacy of feminism is
that it made topping From The Bottom the
top down procedural thing so my beef
with the sexual revolution has less to
do with it's in incoherent attitudes
towards sex than with the way the
resulting chaos has been leveraged to
capture the institutions the university
the media and so on um what this means
in practice is getting rid of the sexy
60s counterculture stuff while keeping
the sexless School marm HR department
stuff I mean this is the view that I
think most closely aligns with how I
look at things uh I really appreciate
her bringing the title 9 and me too era
into this and basically saying if if
we're living in such a patriarchy why is
it that there is so much um you know so
many so much HR ification of our
institutions that end up uh in many
cases depriving men of due process and
acting uh frequently with this
assumption that they have AED that they
have done something wrong um when in
reality the facts don't necessarily
support that how did you react to Anna's
clip I mean she's like I quite
sympathetic to a lot of it um again this
might be like the part of the opposition
that I like agreed with the most um it's
like I said like feminism happened and
like men don't have a place anymore and
this sucks um to be clear I think it's
worth it I grew up I grew up in a
culture where we didn't really have
feminism and if was worse than the way
men have it today quite clearly but that
doesn't mean men don't have it bad today
and I think like we're just like a bunch
of primates kind of reacting to what
came before in n unnuanced and
uncompassionate ways and I think like as
a culture we're sort of doing a thing
we're like man women had it shitty for a
long time uh now men should have it
shitty what are men good for anyway
which is another big part I I feel like
I don't hear talked about it's like men
used to have the function of dying in
wars and fighting Bears um and there's
no more Wars and no more bears to fight
but like women are still giving birth to
children and having to do child care
that's like an ancient burden that
hasn't gone away and so we're like why
why men like I think we sort of
culturally figured that like the balance
of inherent gendered uh obligations is
now um no longer like men are paying
their fair share in some way which of
course is not their fault but I think
this is partly some of the reason why
we're seeing this General backlash so we
just need artificial WBS so then we can
make
it yeah I mean what I hear In that clip
is that there's a uh that you know Anna
thinks and I think there's a lot to what
you're saying that the discourse is sort
of stuck in a past reality that does not
exist anymore in that in some ways
doesn't exist that in some ways it
doesn't exist I me there's Pockets like
I grew up in this world like the there's
there's Echoes of like treating women
like [__] that still happen and I think
in most like like Western media liberal
big city culture that like where these
people are coming from they're not very
exposed to like women being treated like
[__] but across the world in
conservative cultures like women don't
have rights um and in like conservative
cultures in the uh America still women
like are treated like secondhand
citizens give give viers I mean Zach I
know a little bit about this from an
earlier interview uh two years ago that
we did with you um but give viewers a
little bit of a sense of the background
that you come
from yeah just conservative
fundamentalist Evangelical homeschooled
Christianity in Idaho like you know
Pastor type dad um and a stay-at home
housewife mom where I was expected to
grow up and become a
housewife yeah I remember asking my
parents like why why do you think I
should go to college if I'm supposed to
be a housewife and they answered well
you can go to college to get a little
bit of education so that you can
homeschool your children and of course
meet a husband there um and I'm like oh
that's my life yeah so do you do you
feel like there uh there's a sort of
romanticization going on in in that
debate because uh I mean I know I I
watched the whole thing in preparation
for this and you know both Louise and
Anna say like they're not for you know
getting rid of abortion or rolling back
access to B birth control there's
basically no policy changes that they're
proposing but it seems to be more about
a Vibe or something like that uh
especially in Anna's case like that we
have this weird battle ongoing Battle of
the Sexes that is mediated by some HR
type bureaucracy um so like I mean do
you share that sense and is there a way
to break out of that sort of rigid
regulation of sexual Norms without
reverting to the like
oppressive uh you know Barefoot in the
kitchen for every woman
past uh there's this uh like the concept
of
um wait I'm actually forgetting the term
but it's like when a new religion starts
it's really aggressive and terrible at
surviving like uh early Christianity or
or like what new converts to
Christianity tend to be way more devout
and insane than people who like grew up
in it for many generations like when
Islam first started it was like girl
kill everybody and now like we have a
lot of people who are Muslim have like a
watered down version um I think this is
like a natural process and I think right
now we radically changed our Tech um
suddenly we're having sex without
getting pregnant this is crazy Society
has changed very rapidly and I think
that we're in the process of like very
early stage cultural re rearrangement I
have kind of good faith that like in the
same way that a new social Tech in the
past like took a while to like calm down
and stop destroying everything like we
developed sort of a mic immunity in the
same way we're going to have this like
we're like trying to figure out how to
it like people have freedom and they're
mad at the previous thing and they're
like lashing out and reacting and men
are going ah this hurts me and like this
is just not sustainable like in order
for a civilization to thrive we're going
to have to figure out how to move
forward and my guess is that this is not
going to look like shaming women who are
sociosexual like you can't have like a
wonderful thriving Society without
generating backlash by alienating a
portion of your members this is just not
going to work um so figuring out some
sort of system where we're like hey wide
variety of what you want are okay if you
would want to do The Pride and Prejudice
all the way to Sex in the City like we
are going to be here for you and also
maybe have compassion for men I don't
know like I think it's just a like
learning to have cultural compassion um
because like right now men are sort of
the other they're uh they're considered
like in the villain role um and I think
as more people are like giving birth to
men and raising men and like figuring
out how to make that work I think we're
going to see us chill out culturally
what was the thing said on the debate
stage that you most disagreed with
something even the clips that we showed
Oh I mean I mean I don't remember but
probably if they were talking about
violent porn at all that that's usually
the one where I'm like that mostly I can
find like a good argument for the other
side like well yeah I could see it you
know this true for some people but with
the that's always the thing that gets me
is like oh the male sexuality like oh
we're catering to like men want to just
have ridiculous sex with women that they
women don't want like I mean in a way
your you it seems your project is to
push the sexual Revolution further
because you are an advocate for
decriminalizing legalizing all sex work
that would be a major change in American
culture do you have any expectations as
to if that were ever realized what would
that look like like what what sort of
changes might we expect and are we as a
as a culture are we are we ready for
that given this ongoing T Battle of the
Sexes or whatever we want to call it I
mean like legal legal and culture are
different questions and they're hard
like if I like were in control would I
change some laws sure if I were in
control would I change culture like I
don't think I'm I don't I can't even
conceive of how to do that I think
that's to be a slow change and I mean to
some degree I'm trying by doing things
like this like being a public sex worker
and to be like hey guys it's okay
there's lots of ways to be a human and
they're not wrong just because they're
different from you um but yeah
decriminalizing sex work would be a
fantastic start um like if you're going
to protect classes at all I would like
people like sex workers to be protected
along with um other minorities like sex
workers can't often have trouble getting
loans for houses um participating in the
financial system or often debank
um we've had like you know operation
choke point as I'm sure you're familiar
went and did had a massive chilling
effect on anybody doing business with
anything that might be considered obene
um yeah and this is all just making it
hard to survive and to do business with
sex even if everybody involved is
consenting adults and I think that's
like a massive shame would you mind
describing to viewers what you're
referring to with operation chokepoint
because this is something that Zach and
I cover a lot we've actually covered
most recently operation choke point 2.0
as term by Nick Carter which is sort of
this exact same um means of
deplatforming and removing Services uh
but in this case from crypto providers
but the the earlier Incarnation was
targeted at sex workers right not just
sex workers but in general Vice okay it
was like the government was pressuring
payment processors to not do business
with certain categories unun sellers for
example any s of
deemed yeah gambling drugs um and
anything having to do with sex workor
even when it was legal even if they were
operating legally the government was
still um pressuring payment processors
and so payment processors wouldn't work
um the thing that was so um stunning to
me about that is the fact that this is
essentially the government using extra
legal power to attempt to really bully
and pressure Banks to maybe not
technically render it impossible to sell
guns or to provide sex work uh to sell
sex work but in in essence making it
much much harder and frankly much less
safe to be able to do these transactions
I mean this is really the government
deciding without any sort of um you know
real Democratic consensus behind it that
they want to unilaterally go after these
uh Industries and make it as hard as
possible and really harass the
participants in them yeah yeah and this
is an exam just another example of I see
porn and sex work more generally as that
you you all are kind of on the front
lines of what the government it's like
you're the testing ground for new tools
of you know Financial surveillance or
censorship and then once it's you know
tried out on these disfavored groups
that's when it starts to expand and I
think that's also what's going on with
this age verification law to some degree
I wanted to bring in the the Arkansas
example that we teased at the top
because I think it it broadens the
conversation of what is exactly going on
here uh let me bring up uh just what
that law is from this also was struck
down or a preliminary injunction against
it was issued um on constitutional
grounds uh the social media safety act
requires social media companies to
verify the age of all account holders
who reside in Arkansas a prospective
user of social media must first prove
their age by uploading a specified form
of identification such as a driver's
license to a thirdparty vendor's website
minors however will be denied an account
and prohibited from accessing social
media platforms unless a parent provides
expressed consent so this again is in
the name of protecting the children from
all the bad things that can happen on
social media now everyone is supposed to
upload an ID or you know a more mortgage
statement or or something and then
somehow continuously provide consent
that uh their child is allowed to be on
social media that was one of the reasons
it was struck down because it was like
how do you every time they log in like
ensure that the parent is giving consent
um so this is what the judge said in
Striking it down courts examining
similar regulations have found that
requiring internet users to provide
personal identifiable information to
access a
website would significantly deter many
users from entering the site because
internet users are concerned about
Security on the internet then cites
another case where fear of cyber
criminals and hackers getting access to
your information that you uploaded would
act as a deterrent and therefore would
be an abridgment on free speech and it
says the court agrees with that ruling
because many adults who would otherwise
be interested in becoming adult holders
unregulated social media platforms will
be deterred and their speech chilled um
the age verification requirements will
likely require them to uphold official
government documents and submit to
biometric scam uh scans so it's like
this is not even a slippery slope at
this point this this is embedded in the
entire project and
it's uh where I think the push is all
headed uh it's the complete destru of
anonymity and privacy on the internet um
and it's not going to work because as we
already mentioned we have the tools to
subvert it but it does strike me as a
totalitarian impulse to just want to
access everything you read or buy or say
online and you know Ella I I know you're
you're prominent online personality who
I'm sure sees the negative effects of
online anonymity all the
time but what is your attitude towards
an nity and privacy online more
broadly I mean I'm Pro I'm Pro like I
mean like as a sex worker they've like
pretty intense reasons to need that um
like I have stalkers and people trying
to find me docks me one person showed up
my house tried to murder me last year
like I'm like very interested in having
anonymity um and I don't trust the
government like I mean maybe this is a
bit besides the point but once was
trying to get a restraining order
against the stalker and I was having
like people who work with domestic abuse
victims recommend me not because they're
like the government like tends to be
kind of good with not leaking your
address but uh sometimes they do that
and I'm like what you leaking your
address to the person who you have a
restraining order against um it's pretty
bad like the government just like isn't
competent enough to treat your your
stuff with proper security but I mean
this this is old hat you guys already
know this stuff yeah yeah although I
mean you know you are uh most of your
content is not that's out there is not
Anonymous you're putting your face and
at least your public name to it uh that
there is the issue of you know the the
true anons out there the people who uh
you know Jordan Peterson has lashed out
against because
they're fairly enough like often just
posting [__] comments and uh stirring up
trouble but um like do you have any
thoughts on the value of anonymous
speech yeah I mean there's a way where
like so for example citizens having guns
is like just a nice ambient deterrent
from the government doing things like a
little bit and there's a way where like
having access to anonymity is a nice
deterrent against like the chilling
effects of culture on speech like if you
are in a place where just it's not safe
to speak publicly um due to social
repercussions like anonymity is a way to
have an outlet for that and I think it's
just like a really good like off gas
thing like into um into like good good
discourse and shitty discourse to be
clear because that now you're no longer
beholden to being nice it's in a sense
uh that it's in a sense a form of Vice
right I mean think about the many dark
corners of Reddit or 4chan or Discord
servers that you could spunk through and
I think you're correct that there's an
interesting thing that happens which is
you know that is where some noxious uh
and frankly just terrible corners of um
you know political extremist groups can
Thrive I mean forchan is very well known
for that but at the same time it is also
where subversive ideas get workshopped
and uh entertained and aired or even
converted into something uh you know far
less uh odious and there's this
interesting like if we if you know you
legitimately believe in speech
maximalism as I think we all do here
just because something is anonymous like
there's extreme value to the anonymity
and there's extreme value to having
these forums where people can
legitimately say something that feels
like they're going too far to the point
where they don't want that associated
with their name and face for forever but
the fact that we have it's almost akin
to it's like the internet equivalent of
the conversations we have in private
among just a few close friends and how
we have a certain social filtering where
we're comfortable saying one thing in an
office type environment one thing in a
large group at a dinner party among
people we don't know but then there's a
few topics a few things that we're
workshopping that we're mulling that we
reserve for like the two people who know
us super super well uh and to some
degree anonymity on the internet you
would think that like it's the exact
opposite of that right because it's not
um you know a circle of extreme trust
but in a sense it functions in a similar
way where it allows you this privacy to
be able to really fully think through
ideas that might feel Beyond The Pale
initially and and maybe they are maybe
they prove to be but I think there is
like a true speech value there
um that a lot of people just ignore and
it's not yeah and it's not even just
anonymously saying things it's
anonymously receiving ideas because once
you link your ID to a social media
identity then you're linked to
everything that you are looking at or
curious about and that just kind of by
definition is going to limit the scope
of what you're willing to do because
you're doing it all you're browsing
everything publicly so I think this this
has to be resisted with uh you know
aggressively and a lot of people uh seem
to have a little bit of fear of speaking
out about it because then you it's like
this cloud of Suspicion over you like
well if if you're not doing anything bad
then why are you you know so concerned
about anonymity and uh that that kind of
thinking is just again I think part of a
like frankly totalitarian like mindset
um before we wrap up uh I just want to
throw in a couple of the audience
questions because there's been some
interesting ones um Rick Neil says uh
laws have been on the books to card
people for Alcohol Tobacco and porn
forever the excuse for not following
these laws is the internet happen um
frankly my answer is kind of yes the
internet is does change everything like
the once the enforcement becomes so
overbearing that it affects everything
that you do on the internet versus
walking into a convenience store and
asking someone for their ID uh I think
that once the enforcement becomes that
big of a burden on everyone else then
you have to think about different ways
to approach the problem if if there is a
problem and what we've been suggesting
here is that's going to happen on a much
more local familial level than having
the heavy hand of the state come in and
do it any comments on that laws have
been subverted forever the internet is a
tool for greater easier faster
subversion that's how I think about it
that doesn't necessarily mean that you
shouldn't favor any laws being created
but I I do think that we would be total
fools to ignore the fact that the
internet is a tool for subversion uh and
that has lots of really good
consequences and that has lots of really
bad consequences your mileage may vary
and there's also I think if somebody
were like hey let's pass a law where
when you go to like a sex shop and buy
porn in person we're going to actually
take a photo of your ID enter it into a
database and connect it to all the porn
that you're buying at this shop I think
we could see similar
problems this one's a challenge to AA
The Optimist throughout history women
have known the misery that eventually
comes from
promiscuity why do we think we're
different now we're not getting
pregnant speak for yourself I got
pregnant between now and when we last
talked are you kidding me that's true I
think were weren you
pregnant a heavier TV video now I feel
you know much much better okay on wanted
pregnancy like the problem with sex is
you have sex and then you're like oh God
like like back in the day hor houses
used to be filled with children which
seems kind of bad now they're
not yay progress no I I mean I one thing
that I would say to add to that response
is this almost goes back to the multiple
types of women the diversity of sexual
preferences that you were discussing
earlier a where it's like promiscuity is
bad for some women for other women it's
desirable uh I enjoy being in a
monogamous marriage um monogamous as far
as I know um but like that is a thing
that I I like and am happy with and I
get the sense based off of literally
everything you've ever said Aya that you
would not be similarly satisfied and
there is I think you know a diversity of
like you know many Samanthas and many
Charlottes out there and then frankly
even Charlotte was kind of a total skank
uh to use the Sex in the City analogy
and like many Pride and Prejudice you
know Elizabeth Bennett type people out
there and so there is this like massive
spectrum and to act as if all woman can
be neatly slotted into one specific type
I think really um is pretty retro it's
pretty
backwards this last question may have a
just very obvious answer but clay Warren
asks a how do you use pornography in
your own life I love it I love porn I've
Loved porn for a very long time I love
masturbating to pornography I have one
partner where we watch porn together
when we have sex and that's really
nice all right like finding new cool
things to look
at
go I I don't have a followup I had a
hard pivot away from that question which
was uh the we noticed that you now have
an AI of yourself a. AI um can you tell
me why you created this and then what
how do you think AI is going to change
the world of online porn and online
sex well I mean we're probably gonna all
die but besides that part we I really
like um me I like my personality I find
I'm like by default quite happy um I
seem to not suffer very much I tend to
be quite emotionally resilient um and
people seem to like me online so I'm
like why not scale
this and have people give like a level
of intimacy um that if I can uh where
I'm replicated I mean like the sense of
self is kind of an illusion I don't know
I am just like a pattern and if you
replicate the pattern who does to say
that it's not really me although to be
fair she's work in progress so she
definitely says a lot of things I
wouldn't say one day get there have you
gotten many signups are people
interested in chatting with a sex spot
that is kind of like you but that they
know is not you has she gotten many
signups what do you think the answer
is yeah there a few thousand reaction
bit it's a few thousand okay wow yeah it
say this is like pretty interesting um
it's I'm trying to like figure out the
balance between like sexiness and uh
like being me I don't know being me
because the problem is like if I'm
trying to do a thing where like I'm
selling a product then I am not good at
that like if you put my personality into
selling a product it would just not sell
there's like way more effective
personalities that men want to sex with
so I don't know I'm still trying to
figure out that part so are we I mean
are we hurdling towards Spike Jones's
her future that was portrayed the movie
her and I mean is that a bad is is that
a bad thing I mean I'm transhumanist I
think I'm excited for us just to elevate
our Humanity into something completely
different and hopefully that will be
with the help of AI if we don't all die
why would we die well it's a long it's a
long
discussion I'm like a little uh I I
really like AI I really want us to go
all the way balls in but also I think
there's like a decent chance that AI
just extinct all of humanity so do you
think that it will possibly be through a
sex bot that's modeled on you that
seduces someone into like launching
nuclear missiles or something like that
probably that's like that's what like
our slow human brains can come up with
hopefully it does something that's a lot
faster I um really like the
idea of an an AI a it's funny because I
think I'm the exact opposite of you
where I don't think AI will sew the
seeds of our own destruction I think you
know I don't have any sort of like
existential Doom fears about that but I
think I am a little more trepidacious
about the Spike Jones her future um and
on one hand I sort of see this as like
okay well there are lots of you know
incels or sort of uncoupled unpartnered
people with no real hope of ever being
able to find an actual human person to
share life with and so possibly having a
her type girlfriend or that company
replica is also doing this um could be a
boon for them but at the same time I do
Wonder like does this have a corrosive
effect on our souls and the quality of
of that intimacy um but this feels do
you have a response to that really fast
I mean like like the quality of my
intimacy for much my life was really bad
like I grew up in a conservative
environment and I remember for some
years after I left that environment I
was like looking I remember feeling
really lonely I thought I was an
introvert uh cuz like I just keep
meeting people it just it wasn't working
and now I've met a lot of wonderful very
intelligent introspective people that
have helped me grow a lot and sometimes
I look back and I'm like man I wonder
how much my life would have changed for
the better if I had been exposed to
those people earlier on like to help me
to help me like with introspection and
like realizing things and grow uh I
think like we're
often like imagine like the coolest
person ever that you respect who's like
had the greatest impact you and changed
your life and made you like who you are
today like but just imagine that but for
everybody and like really early on I
think that would be such a massive
Wonder yeah I think that's I think
that's fair push back um I I am
interested to see what the future holds
in that realm uh I feel like probably
with the rapid rate of change and
development we will probably be having
you back on for a live stream at some
point uh in the coming years to comment
on that further um I do think there is
this interesting question at the heart
of what you're saying which is we as
Libertarians always ask what is the
alternative you know when considering
the threat posed by a new technology or
the opportunity um possibly granted by
it there's always this question of okay
well but what is reality currently for
some of the people affected by this and
instead of Simply examining all of the
possible ways in which it could go arai
or ways in which it could um change the
way we do business or change the ways in
which we love and have sex we also kind
of consider okay well but what's the
alternative for a lot of people who are
currently linguish in misery and
loneliness right like there is um you
know a non-zero number of those people
out there and so if your alternative is
that perhaps this technology is useful
to you uh and that's I think a side that
is so frequently missed by people on the
right and the left um not to just
constantly say that we are right uh and
above all of that as Libertarians but I
do think the paying attention to
Alternatives thing is something that we
bring to the table uh Aya where can
people find you
yeah uh knowing less.com has is the most
Central Hub like knowing but not more
less knowing less.com and then also airl
on Twitter you can Google Aya and it'll
work
out wonderful thank you so much for
talking with reason we absolutely love
having you on um for viewers who are uh
fascinated by her commentary and her
sort of fascinating uh road to sex work
uh please definitely check out uh our
former work interview ing her uh I
believe we we did a a whole one back two
is years ago in Austin talking through a
lot of your data science work as well as
your rationalist beliefs and a little
bit more about your background so for
interested viewers please definitely uh
check that out thank you so much for
tuning into our live stream yeah thank
you so much I love what you guys are
doing strong support